the way that the dopamine system was
designed to enhance focus is that when
you are excited about something or you
really want to attend to something it
literally brings about a narrowing of
the aperture of your visual window and
your auditory window so that you attend
to this particular location in space and
then events within that location and
space become extremely important and
extremely relevant and that brings about
perhaps the most important point which
is that for most people provided that
they are cited mental focus follows
visual focus in the past when we weren't
so in n undated with devices and
distraction that was probably easier to
do we didn't need such rigid blinders MH
but in fact we do need blinders and many
people actually benefit from things like
putting on a hoodie or wearing a hat
actually V limiting their visual window
and restricting their visual window can
be very helpful for people to learn how
to use visual Focus to Anchor cognitive
Focus